hello there oh that's what everyone's saying
on youtube i bet right right greg and john
here joined by ace ace has to get up bright and
early because he has his own panel at star wars
celebration to do yes he is the biggest star
wars guy that i know and i was like you gotta
join us for obi-wan we're trying to get him on
here for a while keep saying no we're looking
people follow you ace squad leader ace on twitter
and instagram and my youtube channel at first cup
you guys watch movie trivia movie trivia star wars
champ over here you better bring the goods today
you better bring the goods pressures on
pressure's on i gotta know everything you
gotta know everything is you gotta make us
look good and yeah this is first time ever
being here and we're throwing him into a lion's
den two episodes of obi wan's this is episode
one reaction today full length watch along
where you sync up with the time code is for
our super sexy rejects over at our patreon page
cover a whole bunch of shows over there as well
please leave a like that would be very
much appreciated and very important
subscribe and click that notification bell get
notified when our reaction for episode two is up
goal is to get that up one as soon as possible i
know i said the sentence weird sorry about that
lastly then boys at prepper thanks for helping
us edit down these highlights let's get to it
people my god
okay i just wasn't sure what
planet this was oh it is oh my god
it's oh my we're gonna see we're going
to see the killing of the younglings
yes oh my god are we really
going to say this right now
oh my god jesus order 66 bro this is incredible
we got live action clone troopers
right here this is so cool
i mean what were you gonna do
oh my god what an opening
yeah one of those kids has to be grown up
i don't care people say i'm never gonna get sick
of tattooing but never hope we never leave more
tattoo we not saying more sand more sand please
more more there he is and there's there they are
yeah it's crazy we got inquisitors
in live action it's pretty nuts man
i love this you know what we do you and jedi in
actuality i would say the jedi hunt themselves
maybe he's looking for people like him he
comes across this establishment nice place then
he sees you he's like hans
landa from a glorious bastard
you offer him a place to hide fresh
water shade from the sun's in his undoing
wow
yup that's the safety brother bro oh damn that's
the shafty brother yeah it's benny right yeah
prepare him for interrogation you're wasting your
time you know that right you'll never find a song
that'll stop them it did really slow them down
you are reckless he is not yours to find we are
past this third sister i will not warn you again
mm-hmm third forget this fixation with kenobi or
i will relieve you of your duties is that clear
yes consider them forgotten i love how she got
so sick of the grand inquisitor's monologue she
has to hear this every day that's a good point
she just threw the knife waited for someone
hello there
good to see you again
i'm just so happy you and mcgregor
gets to step back into this world
with like better effects and [__]
i i hope like qui-gon is like his
roommate he already hangs out with him
do you have it
i'll give you t16 i'll give you 50. but
when he's playing with it you guys know
what i'm talking about right hey don't ever ask
us that question always assume yes master master
he was like i should probably
kill that boy before he turns evil
experience has taught me one thing
for a fleeting moment i could end it
that moment passed
yeah that's totally it yeah wow
that's we're all thinking about it
same time's crazy you'll draw too much attention
but i have nowhere to go they're hunting
me you have to help me stay hidden
live a normal life what about the people that need
us what about the fight the fight is done we lost
there is a bit of like a little glass
jedi quality to him yeah except we know
he's gonna but i also feel like that's like
oh my god is this older this is alderwrong
it totally is ah
are we gonna see this place
oh my god everybody i recognize the older one
right away oh good for you i'm good for you
i'm saying that i mean if we're going to see a
baby luke then baby leia oh my god that means
we're going to see jimmy smith's baby yeah battles
back baby and if you behave i will let you oh
ah trying to get some training in
wow it's that one droid we got a little
leia here it's incredible the aging
it's a very lovely prison don't worry one day
that prison will blow up we talked about this
when the time comes he must be trained like you
trained his father bird anakin is dead ben and i
won't let you make the same mistake twice so leave
him on the farm with his family where he belongs
does he not know that anakin became darth vader
there's a jedi hiding on this planet we need to
know where he is don't look at it or you'll
be punished hands go first that way when you
reach for anything you think of us you have no
rights here we're not under the empire oh my god
you know something wife kids you
think you could protect them from me
tell me where the jedi is or this
man and his family die oh my god
you know
if you remember anything rewards
will be given stand down third sister
i love how the inquisitors are
like she's out of control guys
she's not gonna talk to hr she's one of the
bad ones she's not a good inquisitor you know
you still want kenobi what is it you think
you will gain by capturing him when i'm old
i wonder if she's like the one from the jennifer
order vendetta with a mentor or something
can they see you waving
it
thank thought you was him in the background you
know my father says they never let you leave
this planet they don't want anybody to know about
you because you're not one of us your father you
want him to like you so you repeat what he says
even though you don't really know what it means
being like him will make people frightened of
you but really you're the one who's scared i
may not have seen much cousin but i can see
that damn laying the law down why are you here
just waiting for what for you what the hell
that's hot from the chili peppers yes yes
i was like the side looks like him
he's gonna sit in with max rebo
just ran into that branch
good
she's as important as he is it's been
10 years i'm not who i used to be
[__] you
she's like but it's a boy she's a girl she
doesn't matter as much see how things work
oh it's safety
could save them obi-wan scratch the itch dude
huh
i i think so that's him
papa qui gone one with the force he's
headed for daru oh you're not quite
nah not the first signature behind the
freight transport the ship is on its way
there now there is no one i trust more with
my child than you for her one last fight
god i love you with mcgregor's performance
in this is so so much pain in his eyes dude
so many great little nuances my father will rescue
me he'll send a whole army no one's coming for you
there's some cheesy acting from
time to time i think it's maybe him
i kind of like flea i'm more
distracted by it the fact that it's
i think that's the biggest distraction
he's gonna pull it out the lightsaber
whip it out man he's immediately
just going to cut it open in lane
first so much better first resort
i love it he fought beside a father during
the war he'll come the jedi will hunt himself
damn she knows who leia really is
well you're coming or not
is
this is like his logan what that was an hour yeah
that felt like it was a half hour that went by
so fast it's about 48 minutes oh that went by
so quick didn't it oh my god i really thought
there was like 30 more minutes left didn't it
this is all about leia yeah it's kind of amazing
biggest surprise i love that we got to move on
to the next episode so we'll just talk for just
a couple of minutes because yeah it's really
late at night that we're probably this yeah
but uh so keep a lookout for them but but yeah
let's just wait to see if there's a post credits
and we'll talk about it a little bit i don't think
there's a post credit scene no especially probably
not if they put two episodes at once yeah this
is just the first time ever the screening and the
streaming service has been like you know what just
watch the credits yeah that's true they don't need
to shuffle you into something else next episode
next episode you're done with this new show
hey we got so much stuff all right i mean i
thought it was a really good first episode we
got another episode of watch so we there's no need
for us to talk for super long but right now what
i'm currently loving is eva mcgregor's performance
uh primarily joel edgerton's and uh like as usual
the effects are really good i like the setup of
the story a lot there are times where it what i
find interesting is weird i don't know if you guys
will agree with me at all of this what i found a
little funny is joel edgerton and um and even
mcgregor are back and they're giving such like a
gritty realistic performance it's so like real
and such an antithesis to help the prequel acting
often felt and then there are other performances
that kind of feel like they're in the prequest
like a little bit like the safety brother felt a
little cheesy to me the riva character someone i
don't really find sometimes it feels like acting
to me whereas the other ones feel so like those
two feel so real and some of these other people
like the little little leia feels like child actor
good one charming but yeah that's just kind of my
opinion but i still really enjoyed it a lot i'm
really loving the themes of you know facing your
your traumas and um and also like yeah this whole
thing of he never really seemed to give a [__]
about me and now he's going out there to go look
after her and protect her and especially that'll
tie in even stronger to the whole thing of help me
obi-wan kenobi your only hope there's a tiny one
stronger than that um so yeah uh i i think jimmy
smits can be in back his tubes and seen ultron
you know things like that's really exciting i know
he's gonna have a lot to say so john why don't
you go first there's an alderaan referencing
californication flea cameo at all in damn so put
down my every youtubers your job is to you know
i'm just being like kind of critical just to you
know you balance the scales here so don't like
kiss asses so yeah john you go next i mean that's
the funny thing is to me like i think everybody's
gonna have a sort of different experience with
which characters blend in the most and which
ones kind of stick out and to me it was the safety
brother actually who i was like i've seen this guy
give amazing performances and i was like this is
all adr and all just like little exposition lines
so yeah it's it's it's interesting to me i like
the pace they've chosen for this i like that it is
a uh more something more i started
listening to it to that legends book
about uh part of it is about you know like
obi-wan living on tatooine and some of it is
sort of similar to what's going on here and i
like that they've gone with something that is
more contemplative even though you have the
looming threat of the inquisitors even though
you have riva who i really enjoyed uh here and
uh yeah it's building to something that's a nice
subversion to me from the at least promos that
we saw thinking okay it's all gonna be about him
keeping an eye on luke and mentoring luke uh and
so yeah to divert from that i think is really cool
and i yeah i just love what ewan mcgregor is doing
at the core of this to anchor it it's like there's
a lot that we're focusing on and establishing
and i think he has a nucleus to all that
and just as a performance you know to ground
everything is is really beautiful and and all
the sort of body language that he's put
in is terrific true true ace my man dude
what did you think uh i talked to the audience
to be honest i loved it but obviously that's a
it's kind of obvious coming from me uh considering
that you know i love ob1 but the prequels i mean
the amount of prequel i kept saying it throughout
the reaction but the amount of prequel love that
we got throughout this was like just insane i've
never seen that much like prequel callback and
obviously the show is this is the first time
the show is you know touching on the prequels
usually we've seen the mandalorian and
boba fett which are you know focused
right after return of the jedi but still prequel
love i'm here for and and i love it and i love
that it's so far that everything we've seen is
as long as you've seen the prequels you're good
you know i mean obviously the visitors
are you know after that but i feel like
that's a really cool idea as far as like saying
like remember this stuff this is the main core of
what the story is about uh second thing for me
is the land stuff is just i mean obviously you
mentioned it john but to me it's like it's always
been that question that a lot of people have
always had which i find funny that the show just
tackled it head-on which is why luke why not leia
and why is all this focus on on why does it have
to be a little boy why can't it be the little girl
and obviously yoda says in return of the jedi
i mean emperor's expect but it's one of those
dude but it's one of those questions i know you
messed up god out of here uh but it's one of those
questions that people have always had which is
like why all this focus on luke and why not on
leia who's keeping an eye on leia i think it says
george lucas came up with it a little bit later
but it's always been that kind of funny remark
as far as like obi-wan looking after luke and
even in this episode where he's like but it but
it's luke though it's it's the glory it's the boy
i'm after the boy he even said the boy like twice
yeah and it's like always been that kind of funny
thing as far as like it has to be a board yeah
which is kind of a cool bait and switch that the
show has really done like the show really did
try to convince us as far as trailer-wise that
it's gonna be obi-wan on the run and maybe some
you know looking after luke kind of stuff but not
anything having to do with leia yeah so that that
to me is the coolest and obviously seeing alderaan
again after revenge of the sith it's i mean
i recognized it and i was just like oh my god
we're going to see leia we're going to see all
iran yeah well i think living in the lifestyle
of alderaan is really cool yeah actually
we've never seen what it looks like inside
yeah like anywhere yeah yeah i mean not just even
aesthetically but you know really getting a sense
of what the people are like in the environment and
such um i really like that i i would say i really
really like the like i'm not on quite the the lo
there are things i definitely loved about the pi
about this first episode and i would say overall i
really really liked i think like what was smart is
like how you were talking about with the prequels
of knowledge is that they're grounding this in
the emotionality of it all first and foremost
and that's the big part of like even mcgregor's
performance is something out of logan you know
and i find i do find the whole relationship the
the con the conflicting relationship with him and
uncle owen to be the most compelling part and it
does make sense to kind of go in a different
direction otherwise you just have another show
on tattoo you know luke you know obi-wan being
like well i won't just give him my gifts man
take my gifts and give it to
luke i'm looking after him
we gotta we gotta throw in some new enough things
because it's another show where like you know a
reluctant hero is about to go look after a kid i
mean there's like other there's comics and books
and such where they could have pulled stories
from but it's like a big part of star wars is
not just directly adapting stuff like letting that
be its own canon letting that exist but then doing
a different story with the shows and the movies so
i think doing this story fills in something pretty
interesting that i didn't see coming i do think
some of the there is parts of the filmmaking that
at times feels like this is the most realistic
star wars thing i've ever seen and then and then
other times i'm like sometimes this feels so much
like a tv show though and so that's where i kind
of go back and forth with some of the aesthetic
like i feel like with the riva character that's
what third sister is called yeah but yeah uh
with that character i feel like i'll be back
and forth because i love the setup of her i love
the i actually love the writing of her i like how
she like she undercuts all the inquisitors like
i'm not one of you i'm actually better and i have
a bigger objective than all of you and so like
even undercutting the grand inquisitor which a
lot of people were excited about and and so uh i
like i really like the setup of her but yeah there
are times where i'm not sure what it is i don't
mind it's not like a weird thing to be like
there's something about it that doesn't
quite read as i don't really believe it
but i'm not i don't i don't know how to explain
it at times it feels like it it hops back forth
feeling like something's so cinematic and
then something feeling like this is a tv show
i think it might come in some of that clash
of direction and it's interesting because yeah
like there are takes on star wars that get more
naturalistic in terms of performance and tone and
there are the older movies that have a different
aesthetic when it comes to those things and i feel
like they're both at work here and it's kind of
blending so that's why i kind of like it because
it's sort of blending both like the prequels
and the original trilogy in terms of tone
so part of me kind of likes that i sometimes
feel that way it's interesting because to me
it's it's not necessarily like oh my god this
is the most amazing episode i've seen but it it
it felt like a steady solid place to first
start first yeah like i i thought it was a
very nice set off into the journey and and you
know i also too appreciate that yeah like you
said it's not just about regurgitating specific
plot points and things from extended material
but yeah it's like taking some of those themes
especially of when the jedi decide not to help
which is something i know that is kind of a theme
explored in some comics and books where it is
obi-wan sort of struggling not to answer that
itch yeah and i like the way that theme plays
in here you know i hope they continue with it
because it seems like the big debate going on
within him yeah i mean i think part of that too
is like he knows that if he does help another jedi
it could possibly expose luke so i think
that's a huge part of why he doesn't get
involved because he's like luke is my priority i
can't be helping anyone else yeah because if i do
that could be exposing luke or leading to luke
so yeah and it makes him really interesting as
the character especially even though we've seen
his anguish in the past of the prequels we also
have you know the alec guinness version to look
forward to who is very sage and very comforting
and i like this middle point of that character
well simultaneously though in some parts of the
performance rita's that's an excuse to not
help you know it's like that's true that is
absolutely true what you're saying about it and
like the choice is true but the same time he's so
aggressively reluctant and resistant he's beaten
towards any form of helping anything with jedi
and it's like his whole belief system has been
demolished his lifestyle he was born into stripped
and just and empty that it's just like no
i i gotta stay in this cave and watch him
i gotta know they're gonna watch him yeah
it's like is this for the bigger purpose
or is it because you don't actually want to
get involved in your struggling with your
faith essentially and now it goes back to the
whole thing that you're talking about with like
leia's kidnapped yeah but i gotta
stay here and watch the boy you know
like sometimes it is a cop out even though
i am endangering him just by being good just
by being this close and you know i'm force
sensitive so they might sense me and this
girl's specifically looking for me um so yeah
it is interesting but uh i'm loving it so far
i feel like it's just gonna get darker all right
guys let's get to it uh we've got one more to go
um along this with the patron of the day shout out
scuba steve scuba let's face it if there's anyone
on our patreon who could be a wandering jedi
it's definitely you except i imagine that you
be the kind of jedi who would uh use the force
for just his own selfish needs scuba would go
around and just steal stuff off of poor people
i mean like hmm that pair looks snatch it away
like a total [__] but the best kind of [__]
because scuba is the kind of [__] that when
someone's still in need of help scuba would still
rise to the occasion and then steal from that
bad guy make sure that bad guy kills whatever
good samaritan is out there and yeah they laid
dead in the street but then he would steal from
that bad whatever that bad guy took from that good
guy scuba would take from that bad guy meaning he
creates balance in the world hence why scuba is
the perfect person to be a jedi at our patreon
page i could say hey we're close to a million
subscribers and scuba has been here with us
with like hundreds of thousands of subscribers
ago sure i could go that route or i could make
some weird sarcastic not that funny patron
of the day shout out calling scuba an [__]
that's the direction i think scuba really
wants and hopes for you know he's got that
east coast grit on him gee nah you know i'm just
messing around scuba diving thanks for watching
scoob sith over here thanks for being around
here for so long that would have probably
been a much easier direction of taking
it from the get-go better this is better
thank you for being here for for a while
buddy you're your demand thank you scuba